although you say it matters not that he
Christ belonged to any particular group
why is it that so many of our Christian
churches still hold sacred a physical
image of a blue-eyed blonde-haired man
on their Church walls when indeed it
only promotes
to pass the buyers seeking truth and our
Young Generation that this is in fact a
visual image
and thank you Pastor it is a long
question and again someone is concerned
about the image or representation of
Christ in art
now we dealt with this the other night I
don't know what you want him to be and
when you say you are seeking truth then
what are you seeking do you want a red
Christ or a black Christ or purple
Christ
and until you find the one you want you
have not found truth
truth is that he was the son of God
would somebody say Amen doesn't matter
what he looks like he was the son of God
and if God had wanted us to know he
would have told us now I happen to look
at this one and there's some reference
to Revelation where it speaks of his
eyes as burning flames is Haya as pure
wool his feet has burnished brass this
is not the Christ that walked the dusty
roads now understand what I'm saying
this is the glorified Christ it's the
same one but it's the one who has gone
to glory to be glorified with his father
as he was before the world was made
and therefore John didn't know him would
you say Amen out now
but it isn't required he was not black
he was not Spanish
he was not Chinese he was Jewish
and Jews in those days were all in
complexion with brown eyes I really
honestly don't know what difference that
makes
truth is he was the savior of the world
and if you miss that you have missed
Heaven next please
this comes from a 12 year old where are
the animals going to go when they die
are they going to go to heaven when God
comes there is no record in the Bible
that they will go to heaven there won't
be any up there when we come back down
to the new Earth We're going to have
animals as they were in the Garden of
Eden
they don't bite they don't claw and The
Lion and the bear and the calf and the
fatling will each straw together the
Bible says next please
a question in the Jewish Sanctuary
service please explain the symbolism of
the red heifer the red HEPA I mentioned
last night the other night when we were
talking about all of these these were
parts of the ceremonial law written by
Moses for the children of Israel and the
regulation of their religious Services
by the way everything that Moses wrote
wasn't nailed to the cross Jesus told us
which were nailed he said those which
were a shadow of things to come but the
body or the substance or the reality or
the Fulfillment was Christ
now everything that pointed to Christ
was a shadow and that was nailed to the
cross the red HEPA offering was one of
those and we are told by Bible scholars
this was one offering that said
specifically Gentiles were to be Heirs
of Salvation this sacrifice was killed
outside the city
and it represented the fact that those
outside of Judaism couldn't be saved
through the blood there is no remission
of sins without the shedding of blood
all of these things pointed to Jesus who
would shed his blood for lost men
everywhere God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish whosoever regardless of who you
are where you come from what your ethnic
background is what your culture is if
you have faith in the Son of God you may
be saved and the red heifer was a
statement back in the days of Israel
which most of them missed next please
uh so you do not believe the church has
the right to change the law that's
exactly right I do not believe that the
church has the right to change the law I
don't even believe that Jesus could
change the law
if he could have he wouldn't had to die
for the Bible says where there's no law
there's no transcription where there's
no law there's no sin he died for sin if
he could change the law he wouldn't have
to die now if the church can move Heaven
and Earth Luke 16 17 then I will grant
the church can change the law next
please
instead of babies being destroyed with
their Heathen parents by the Israelites
couldn't God have spared them because
they were innocent
there is in this question I'm not saying
it's intended
but there is in this question and he
implied the criticism of God
couldn't God have done differently
what's wrong with him I'm not saying you
meant it that way but that's what's
implied I would like to give you a
sincere heartfelt bit of counsel when I
say you I don't know who wrote the
question I mean all of us
never allow your mind to second-guess
God
would you say Amen to that
now God could have done whatever he
willed
and remember God sees the end from the
beginning
and there were people who had gone so
totally away from God that even their
offspring would simply have been
heathens full of hatred toward truth and
God knew it and it was best to rid the
world of it next please is it true that
God compares the Fallen Church to a
harlot which wears lots of makeup and
jewelry you find that in Revelation
chapter 17 and we're going to preach
about it later on and I believe it'll be
very clear next please Pastor Brooks
Kenny man and woman who are married to
other people be friends if so what kind
of friends that's an interesting
question sure you can be friends but not
intimate friends and not romantic
friends you may be platonic friends you
may be friends at a distance you may be
Christian friends
but let us never look for permission of
compromise in God's word or morality
would you say Amen never look for
permission to indulge in immorality even
in the slightest degree God said Jesus
said if you just look at a woman in lust
you've already committed adultery so a
Christian has to be lifted above all the
degeneracy with which he is surrounded
every day and that's where we're headed
that's our goal that's that Higher
Ground we're talking about
one man wrote me a question and said how
can a man be a Christian when women
dress like they do I don't care if women
go naked you can be a Christian
There Is Power
there is a God the problem is the man
doesn't want it
and now look if we appear to be in a
hurry answering your questions it's only
because we are
we are not trying to be short with the
answers next please Pastor Brooks what
can you tell me about soul mates is it
in the Bible no that's not in the Bible
and I'm not sure quite what you mean I
believe this I believe that when a
person is of age and mature and wants to
get married that person is if he's a
Christian can talk to God and God will
help with the process now I have read
from an inspired writer that the brain
nerves are the only medium through which
Heaven can communicate its will to the
entire system if we live close to God he
will speak to our minds so that our
decisions will be in harmony with his
decisions would you say Amen but don't
ever make these choices based on looks
alone now they're not wrong with good
looks but don't make your decision for a
life mate or soul mate based on looks
alone you might turn out to be miserably
disappointed you ought to put character
ahead of looks now if you can get both
of them that's a bonus but put character
first
there's a lot of difference in being
attractive and being pretty
a lot of pretty people are not
attractive
some of them are so proud they think you
owe them a debt of gratitude just to
look at it
but almost anybody can be attractive if
they keep themselves neat and if they
smile easily would somebody say Amen no
don't leave me up here by myself
and you want a Christian
you want a Christian you want a
responsible person if you're a woman you
want a man that knows how to work
you want somebody who is kind and calm
and doesn't fly off the handle who is
not unreasonable you got a brain use
your own brain and when you've done the
best you can pray pray
I will read this just as it is
uh many a woman preach on the pulpit I'm
sure they must have been May a woman
preach on the pulpit there's no
injunction in the Bible against it next
please
why don't we practice the Jewish
holidays like Passover and so forth like
they did in the Old Testament didn't
Jesus mean keep all of my Commandments
including those no and that's a
precisely the essence of that sermon of
what was nailed to the cross
the Bible says let no man judge you and
meat and drink and holy days Sabbath
days new moons
which were a shadow of things to come
all of the ceremonial law pointed
forward to Jesus Paul said circumcision
is nothing uncircumcision is nothing
once Christ died it was fulfilled and
Paul said Jesus or Christ is our
Passover so that's why we don't kill
Lambs we don't put our faith in the
blood of little lambs anymore but in the
Lamb of God who was once offered how
many the Bible says he was once opened
for the sins of man our faith is now in
Christ we do not observe that as
Christians Orthodox Jews still do they
are still looking for messiah I was
writing with a Jewish lady in Israel and
she said pastor Brooks our idea of the
Messiah is so real we expect him at any
time I said ours is too
but we don't expect him to come as a
babe he did that over 1900 years ago
when he comes again he's coming as a
conquering King he's coming as a
deliverer
that's what I believe
next please if Jesus did away with the
law does that mean the law of the Old
Testament days such as the eating of
certain foods oh go ahead does it mean
that we ignore that that law it's got
two parts to it well let's start with
that one what Jesus did away with from
the Old Testament the law of Moses was
that part of it that was symbolic a
shadow of things to come
now if Jesus told the Jews not to drink
poison that's not a shadow
that's for anybody poison doesn't just
kill Jews it kills everybody would you
say Amen
but those things which were spiritual
which pointed to Christ once Christ came
you don't need anything Deport to him
anymore except communion and baptism and
Faith next please part two are faiths
that were our faiths that worship on
Sunday condemned
that's not the point the word of God is
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
there are people who don't know any
better once you know and you persisting
wrong you are condemned you are under
the condemnation of the law next please
this is the last one Pastor Brooks all
right how many words are in the Bible
sooner or later we're gonna get that one
now it depends on original Bible you're
talking about the Bible I like to bring
to the pulpit is the King James the
reason I do it is because that's the one
that is most common I have several
versions of the Bible but the King James
is the most familiar to the most people
and in there you have 773
746 words and uh people ask questions
like that because often they already
know the answer
they want to see if we know
if you'd like to know how many letters
are in there ask us but the important
thing is that you do what those words
say would you say Amen out there
some of the people who do Black Arts
claim that their gifts come from God
please comment well of course I have
often received these brochures and
things and folk will say they were born
behind the seventh Veil you ever read
that and that God gave them a special
gift ladies and gentlemen these are just
claims they are not the truth God does
not contradict himself in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter 18 I begin with
verse 10. there the Bible says there
shall not be found among you anyone that
maketh his son or daughter to pass
through the fire or that useth
divination or an observer of times or an
enchanter or a witch or a Chama or a
consultant with familiar spirits or a
wizard or a necromancer for all that do
these things are an Abomination unto the
Lord
would you say Amen now why would God
change his opinion
these things do not come from him
we read to you the other night that Saul
died because he visited the witch of
indoor you read that in first Chronicles
chapter 10 and verse 13. in Revelation
chapter well I won't even read that one
in Malachi chapter 3 and verse 5 let's
see what the Bible says Malachi 3. I
hope I wrote down the right text Malachi
3 and the fifth verse
and I will come near to you to judgment
and I will be a swift witness against
the sorcerers against what
and against adulteress and against false
swearers and so forth God put Sorcerers
in the same class with adulterers and
the Bible says no sorcerer will inherit
eternal life
Now ladies and gentlemen they got all
kinds of Brands and species
you got powder Sprinklers and and palm
readers and card readers and and
incense burners and necromancers these
are folk who deal with the dead today
they call them channelers all of these
people it's spiritism it is a an
Abomination to God it is an art or
science that is fraught with demonology
and demons help them perform miracles
they do not please God if you've got a
problem you better go to God In Prayer
or the devil will deceive your mind and
some people never recover next please
Pastor where does it tell us in the Old
Testament of the second coming of Jesus
oh there are several let me give you one
that's very familiar job had been
Afflicted and was sick and and he
thought he was dying and he had these
miserable comforters his friends who
told him the reason you're sick is
because you did wrong and job was
protesting I am a Christian I am a child
of God and he uttered these words you
hear at funerals all the time I know
that my redeemer liveth and that he
shall stand at the latter day upon the
Earth
though after my skin worms destroy this
body get in my flesh shall I see God not
only that but the psalmist said that the
day would come when the Lord would
return with ten thousand of his Saints
a fire extreme shall they ship before
him and it shall be buried tempestuous
round about him in both Old and New
Testament the Bible pointed forward to
the coming the triumphant coming of our
Lord and not only that you'll see it in
tonight's sermon next phrase
Mr Brooks why are there so many versions
of the Bible it has been translated so
many times can we trust it and then some
of the books that we hear about are not
included in the Bible why two questions
asking virtually the same thing now I'd
like to tell you what I have said to
others who send such a question in first
of all you better thank God for
translations
unless you are thoroughly acquainted
with Hebrew Greek and Aramaic
now I don't imagine many of you are
these preachers up here are but most of
you are not some might be but not enough
of you and without translations we
wouldn't know the word of God now I
cannot possibly believe that the word of
God would be so important to us and to
our Salvation and God wouldn't Shepherd
the translation of it it was his doing
would you say Amen out there so that we
could understand his word the Bible was
not originally written in English or
Spanish
it was written in Hebrew Arabic and
Greek so we are thankful that God has
given through different Scholars and men
and all gifts come from God he has given
us translations
now there are several as you have said
but the things you really have to watch
are interpretations interpretations
you have to watch paraphrases because a
man who does it infuses his own Concepts
and Scofield bible is one of those by
the way the living Bible is very popular
with young people I have it I have the
Scofield bible but you'd better know
what God's word says are there little
sections where you will be misled by
commentary done by the authors so number
one thank God for translations number
two be careful of paraphrases and
interpretations because people give
their own personal convictions and
flavor to those now you ask about books
that are not there they are the
apocryphal books of the Bible and you'll
find them in some of the large editions
and in the Catholic Bible they are not
inspired the authors do not claim
inspiration
they are often very good historical
sources but they are not inspired as are
the writings in this Bible which is the
King James or authorized version
this is one of the most Dependable you
can ever read the revised version
revised standard these are good
translations choose one that you're
comfortable with this is the one that
most people have that's why I bring it
into this Pulpit apocryphal books are
not included we do not use them as
references because the authors did not
claim inspiration next please
Pastor if a person does not know how to
read what will happen to that person and
then is it all right to hear songs that
are not necessarily church songs if a
person doesn't know how to to read there
are many people who don't know how to
read but who love the Lord and who
follow him there's a text in the Bible
where Philip was joined to the Ethiopian
eunuch he didn't know how to read but he
didn't know how to understand he was
reading the scroll in his Chariot and
Philip said understand is thou what thou
read is he said how can I understand
without someone to teaching me so Philip
got up in the under the power the Holy
Ghost and taught him now if you don't
know how to read There Are Places to
which God will lead you I don't believe
anybody's in this Auditorium tonight by
accident I believe God brought you here
now there are many other places you can
go and you can get the ideas of men but
you've got sense enough to know when the
Bible is being used and God is speaking
to your heart
and so if you don't know how to read
then know how to listen know how to pray
the slaves didn't know how to read
they were forbidden by the law to learn
how to read
and if anybody taught him that person
would be punished and yet some of the
most noble Faith was held by those
slaves and all god holds you responsible
for is the best you can do would you say
Amen out there now uh can we hear songs
that are not church songs sure they are
songs that are uplifting the the rule is
not whether it's a church song or not
but the rule is it is is it an enobling
song or is it a degrading song
I'll be dead honest with you I was
driving home last night and a Jeep load
of young men pulled up beside us and
they were in their Jeep they had a right
to do what they did but they had some
rap music going and it was so loud
everybody at that red light was hearing
it and I thought to myself that is
madness
it sounds like something that would
emanate from an insane asylum
and the lyrics
drag your mind down to the dirt
now they are light Classics and other
nice music that are not necessarily
church songs that will not do that to
you you don't need a preacher to tell
you if you get the Holy Ghost you will
automatically turn off to stuff like
that
next please Pastor here's a person that
wants to know why don't we get all of
our prayers answered all of the time you
know what I say mine are answered all
the time not always the way I want
remember God is our father and he knows
what's best for us not only that the
Bible says the Holy Spirit maketh
intercession for you with groanings that
cannot be uttered by the human throat
ladies and gentlemen if we got
everything we asked for many of us would
be lost
some people ask to be a millionaire and
God knows if you got a million dollars
you'd stop praying you'd become proud
I read from what inspired writer God
gives us all the money he can trust us
with so when you're asking for a million
dollars the holy spirit is saying no
don't give him a million if you give him
a million he'll be lost
huh
so God does answer prayer sometimes he
says yes
sometimes he says wait a while
sometimes he says no and every answer is
given in love to the sincere heart now
there are some texts that you ought to
read one of them is Psalm 66 and verse
18. there the Bible says if I regard
iniquity in my heart the Lord will not
hear me after God has shown you his will
and you know it but you don't do it
you're wasting your time praying amen
the Bible says that Proverbs 28 and the
9th verse says if you turn away your ear
from hearing God's law even your prayer
is an abomination amen
don't forget those two texts one says if
you know you've got iniquity iniquity is
plain sin it's sin after you know better
if you're harboring that God will not
hear you and the other one says if you
turn away your ear from hearing God's
law
your prayer is an abomination
there's one last text found in the first
chapter of the Book of James it says let
him ask in faith nothing wavering for he
that wavereth is like a wave of the seed
driven with the wind and tossed let not
that man think he shall receive anything
of the Lord so when you ask ask in faith
and believe that God is know that he's
there and know that he has your best
interest at heart and then you can pray
thy will be done
Pastor Brooks I hear strange noises and
odd things in my house is this a ghost
or a spirit can a house be haunted by
such things well we did a whole sermon
out here and then we did follow-up
questions on the state of the Dead the
Bible tells us that the dead knew not
what
now didn't the bible say that did you
check it
the Bible says that When a Man Lies Down
he riseth not till the heavens be no
more when will that happen that's not
talking about heaven where God is
talking about the atmosphere of Heavens
Saint Peter said in Chapter 3 of the
second division that the heavens will
pass away with a great noise when Jesus
comes and a man who died will not rise
until then
then the Bible says he shall return no
more to his house amen now you've got to
believe what the Bible says the first
lie ever recorded was the devil's lie in
Genesis 3 ye shall not surely die and
Satan has built a great Empire called
spiritualism well who are these things
and what makes this noise the Bible says
in Revelation 16 14 amongst other places
they are spirits of devils working
miracles Satan confusing Satan
destroying Faith Satan trying to torment
you into submission to era
in your home if you hear these noises
you ought to turn to God with such
stubborn Faith Satan will decide to
leave you alone Pastor Ortiz and I were
in a little island called Saint Kitts
and we we win a very humble Hotel
humble Hotel
and and in my room I was preaching the
gospel and in my room it began to happen
every night about three o'clock I'd hear
these noises
and I I'm not that wonderful I'm not
that confident but I sure do believe in
God
and when I heard it one night after
about three nights I I just woke up and
I started laughing I said Satan you
might as well go on and try somebody
else you can't fool me with this junk
next day I was looking around in my room
and somebody had put a little bottle in
there with a piece of gut in it looked
like chicken gut I started to throw it
in the trash I said no I'm gonna put it
out in the Hall so they'll know I found
it
and know that I know that it means
nothing
it's going to take more than a chicken
gut to damn meat
I believe in God
and the old spiritual says Satan can't
do me no harm
here's a young Seeker for truth nine
years old does God have a father and
does his father have a father how long
has God been here
there are three that bear record in
heaven first John 5 7
and that is the father a word and Holy
Ghost
Jesus referred to his heavenly father as
father many many times in the New
Testament but not father in the sense
that Christ was born Christ is a
co-equal with God Amen Christ is verily
God
the difference was he became man and was
also called the son of man but the
Father the Son and the Holy Ghost these
three are one God first John 5 7 and
ladies and gentlemen there never was a
time that any one of them did not exist
so you cannot Trace them to a birth or
to a creation they are Eternal God
Pastor why don't we observe Passover and
praise God and celebrate Hanukkah and
the Festival of Lights wouldn't this
remind us of our Jewish ancestors and
how they were delivered
oh beloved oh beloved oh beloved
I always fear someone wasn't present
when I painstaking life
preach these truths now I'm not
impatient don't misunderstand
but if you take a look at that cross
over there
if you I believe in Christianity and in
the scriptures
Saint Paul said in Colossians 2
that Jesus took that out of the way
why because they had no meaning except
to point us to Jesus the Lamb of God now
even Passover because I had questions
about that last night Passover
commemorated the freedom of the Jews
from Egypt when they passed over into
the promised land now we all know that
but it also represents the power of
Jesus to help us pass from slavery of
sin into his kingdom of Grace it all had
symbolic meaning and when Jesus
fulfilled these things Paul said he
became our Passover and so it is not
necessary now if you want to Rejoice do
it
but you ought to do it as a Christian
and not as one confused these Services
no longer have meaning except historical
in the Christian church next please our
final question for tonight Pastor I
can't seem to get past the idea that the
law was Jewish oh I get it I can't seem
to get past the idea that the law was
Jewish well I got news for you if you
love Jesus
he was Jewish
amen
I'll read you a text I don't know if
you're familiar with it or not but I
want you to hear it it's found in the
Book of John
it says ye worshiped ye no not what we
know what we worship for salvation is of
the Jews amen
there it is John 4 22 write it down look
it up
salvation is of the Jews what in the
world does that mean
they became way back when the whole
world had gone astray they became the
custodians of God's law and the keeper
of the Oracles of God it was their
responsibility to share it with all the
world like many of us they became racist
bigoted selfish and they shut out the
Gentiles and in doing this they failed
but the keeping of the truth
the Jews were committed that
responsibility they were God's people
and oh how he loved them
but when they rejected Christ the time
came that they as a corporate people had
to be rejected not as individuals three
thousand joined the church on Pentecost
and thousands more subsequently the
early church was largely made up of Jews
so let's get this nationalism out of our
minds
in Christ there is neither Jew nor
Gentile East nor West male no female
black no white noise says Bond nor free
would you say Amen
but Salvation is of the Jews
Abraham wasn't a Jew
Abraham lived a long time before Isaac's
son Jacob had
children who became
the Jews
I have a little poem I used to
recite if I can remember it
salvation is of the Jews the whole Bible
is Jewish
all of it was written by Jews except one
or two little spikes
one chapter in The Book of Daniel was
written by Nebuchadnezzar and the law
was written by God other than that the
rest of it was written by Jews well you
got against the Jews salvation is of the
Jews and I used to say Bible came
through a Jew to you
and if you expect to go to heaven you've
got to be a Jew too
because the Bible says that modern
Israel is the church
you're a son of well you know what the
Bible says if you be Christ then I.E
Abraham's wife
seed and heirs according to what
the reason I had you helped me quote it
is because I want everybody I know it's
in there if you become Christ you become
Abraham's seed now it won't make you
white and it won't straighten your hair
but it will straighten your heart